Now, let's have you figure out the running time of another algorithm using Big O Notation.
So, this is the algorithm that we are going to look at, it's just four lines
and actually the algorithm does not perform any very useful function.
The most important part is that it's interesting to analyze its running times.
So, there's not really any value or at least none that I can see
of actually producing this result down here.
So, what I would like you to do is to figure out the running time
as a function of this value n here, and I'm going to give you a number of choices for your answer.
So, the first choice is O (n) so it would be a linear algorithm.
The second one is O(n¹. ⁵). Next one is O(n²). And the final one is O(n³).
So, I want you to check the box that states the correct running time of this algorithm
expressed as a function of n, and I'm also going to give you a little hint,
which is that if you add n + n-1+ n-2 and so on plus 2 plus 1 that is equal to n²+n/2.
And once you analyzed the algorithm, you'll see that this hint is actually quite useful.